so these are the kind of things which
they should now become recall this
fluency you know you don't think about
the words that you say in the language
that you were you know raised and born
with because you just they're so they're
they're part of your brain right Frank
did you want to suggest something you
want to do the last T okay we'll get to
the last two a minute I just wanted to
point out for one B I don't know how
many of you but this is your strategy if
you did this and then you wrote down
sorry two four one nine like that what
was the first thing most people did so I
want to put the hand up and give you a
suggestion what's the first thing that
we did okay so a really great thing to
do and before I get to that is to is to
show that this number and this number
i've never be awkward to subtract did
you notice that right if you did the
first thing that most people did you'd
say oh you're taking with neither clock
do that so we borrowed from the next
i'll bomb right but that you got to
probably because you've got not much to
borrow from and it kind of makes a
disaster of your number so another
suggestion of idea which is what the
killers were saying here is that do you
guys agree that five take away four four
take away three three take away 2 and to
take away one do you agree that they all
give you the same on top if you see that
if if i evaluate all these i'm gonna get
the same number right so therefore if i
bring this one down by one i just have
to bring this one down by one it'll
still get the same answer so this is
really the same as 5999 i've brought
that down by one so then I can bring
this number down by one does that make
sense
reduce both of them by one just like I
did here and now it's super easy to go
through because 9 take away a is going
to give
one night takeaway one hey aids I take
away for why and we can see that Billy
was exactly right and there's no
carrying or anything involved it's
really really quick and easy okay
so I don't the tips and tricks okay
someone want to get to me what 210 is as
a product of prime factors I think they
are for Frank equals 5 times 2 times 7
times P okay very good 5 & 7 & 2 & 3
we're exactly right I tend to write them
in a 70 order because that way if I look
at someone else's I can see what you
clearly have the same answer so I go 2
times 3 times 5 times 7 now the last
question don't tell me the easier but
here not even got an answer for it
heads up straight okay thank you heads
down now a lot of you haven't got there
yet
I wonder if you noticed that number 3
and number 4 they kind of connected
together did you notice that you did 210
as a part of its prime factors and this
210 appear again this happens a lot in
math so we're trying to help you out so
we give you two questions and they're
kind of related to each other it's a
flow on it for one big question so if we
know the prime factorization of this
stuff off we can combine it with the
prime factorization of the other one and
then we can use that to find the clients
called factor has anyone already worked
out what my factorization of 224 is
let's do it together okay
224 so we'll want to suggest something I
could divide through by yep easy one
pecan easement
okay so 102 sounded good
well yeah if I preferred to 12 over here
I picked that number because it's
exactly half of two three four so two
times hundred twelve that's good 112
what we'd like to do that by turn I
can't so I can do two over here and that
gives me 56 okay we can pick some bigger
numbers this time because 56 is small
enough for us to know Maria just see in
28 and I'm running out of space very
quickly here 28 years can you give me a
number one retention okay 14 and 2 and
I'm stuck here so I'm gonna and this guy
comes off here
because these are my last two factors
okay seven times two so that means that
should have dropped my treats ball but
also B's had I can write to 24 hours
what are the privates that you see how
many twos do you see I count one two
three four five of them two to the power
of five any other numbers in the other
primes I've got the I've got the seven
okay very good
so how am I going to use this now how
does this help me to do something with
this so want to give us suggestions
every - you've already got this interest
7/7 good and is there anything else as
it's in common there's a yeah there's
just now there's just one - is it there
there are five to TIA
but there is only one of them there so I
could only use one of this one and one
of them okay so I've got a chewing
comment about seven in common what I do
with those okay I can know I can't see
what's the highest but I'm two and seven
it's obviously sevens fire but what do i
do like with them together how can i
combine them together yeah I can
multiply them so the highest common
factor of what did I send it up to it
210 and 224 should be 2 times 7 which is
14 you can go ahead and check it out if
you want like check they get all
multiplied off